the Long Island horticultural research
and Extension Center is a campus of
Cornell University we've been here in
Riverhead New York for 98 years and our
purpose here is to help the agricultural
industry
succeed there is a lot of need for
up-to-date research and assistance with
growing plants the impatiens is
primarily of interest to the greenhouse
growers on Long Island as well as some
of the nurseries the commercial the
retail establishments that sell plants
right here we've been breeding in
patients plants trying to develop
resistance to the disease called
impatience downy mildew and there's
always problems when you do breeding and
one of the one of the issues that we
found out with this plant is they have
what we call explosive seed pods so that
means when the seed pods are ripe thanks
but and of course if you're trying to
harvest seed that's a problem because
then they're all over the greenhouse
floor so we use we use a technique
called plant tissue culture to assist
our breeding program and essentially
plant tissue culture is a way to grow
plants in a sterile environment on a
nutrient medium under controlled
environment so we will remove the pods
that we've pollinated on these plants
about 14 to 16 days after we've
pollinated them and we take those pods
to our laboratory they're sterilized on
the outside and then they're opened
aseptic ly to expose the seeds and those
seeds that are placed in tissue culture
to germinate the nice thing about that
process is is that once they germinate
in tissue culture they're always going
to be there as a stock plan for us
they're ours gonna be available we can
take cuttings of those plans to bring
them out here in the greenhouse if we
find out that we have a successful plant
a successful hybrid we have the mother
plant in tissue culture free of diseases
free of insects and we can then rapidly
propagate that plant to increase the
numbers quickly
and these are the results of some of
that breeding research so all these
plants that you see here are resistant
to the disease we've done field trials
for them for the last two years but our
next step then is to produce a plant
that has a nice looking flower and a
nice symmetrical growth habit so we are
continuing to hybridize these plants and
will continue to develop and until we
get a nice seed profit